People are really shocked that I've never had Coke before, so, I'm actually really excited to see what all the fuss is about.
I'm a big Pepsi fan and I don't know about trying no Coca Cola *laughs*
I just never drank soda when I was growing up.
Diabetes is a big problem in my family and my mom was very strict about sugar.
I grew up with Diet Coke.
I kind of don't know that I will be able to even get past whatever sugar there is in it.
I'm kind of scared.
Oh no!
This is a big deal.
*laughs*
Hmm.
I don't really like it.
Very sugary.
I feel like I need pancakes to pour it on, it's a little thick.
It's almost like rancid BBQ sauce.
I'm okay with never having it again.
I don't know why people drink this.
That's actually pretty good.
It doesn't give me that burping sensation, I love to burp.
It tastes like a burp, a good burp though.
It's the after taste, the after taste is worst than the actual initial taste.
I've been in a long term relationship with Pepsi and I will never leave him for Coke.
People who say they don't like this, I think they are probably lying.
I'm very happy to know what all the fuss is about, now I don't feel like a black sheep among Americans.
This is pretty good stuff.
I've had a lot of better other firsts.
Oh man, this, you may have opened Pandora's box here.
If my mom knew I was drinking this, she would be very disappointed in me.